[Music]
from the studio
who's casually redefined the word
trilogy comes the Hunger Games like
you've never seen them before
hunger Genghis The Hunger Games
Mockingjay part 1
if you thought have a short book
wouldn't have enough plot to carry a two
hour movie you were right prepare for a
slow build up to a climax that won't
come until you pay for the next one kind
of like the last one full of obvious
time filler like repetition President
Snow
President Snow its Katniss President
Snow I need to speak with you are you
there
President Snow its Katniss can you hear
me President Snow its Katniss President
Snow
President Snow a guy whose only purpose
is to walk Katniss to our next scene
president corns requested to meet with
you first you want in a command this way
this way soldier
and lots and lots of nothing
[Music]
and cut after the last games the capital
is murdering everyone in sight now with
a chance to help stop the genocide
Katniss will do everything she can to
not cooperate don't make me do this and
constantly [ __ ] about her fake TV
boyfriend who she really didn't care
about until he gave her a ball about
Peeta was he alive
he left Peeta was the one who was
supposed to live clearly there are more
important things than Peeta going on
right now even if we leave this floor
what happens to Peeta Peeta and the
other tributes will be rescued at the
earliest opportunity sounds like exactly
what Peter said when you all called him
a traitor please shut up about Peeta
it's good it's how did she'd be good to
punish me I know stay there this
revolution is about everyone and you
should have saved Peeta
ah ride along for a movie that boils
down to each side making political
attack ads about each other as Peeta
appears on TV in a series of humiliating
little outfits while Katniss pouts her
way through being the Mockingjay in
scene after scene with all the
excitement of actual film production so
cringe why one of the best supporting
cast of all time is squandered on this
paper-thin half a movie the movies
biggest hunk is squandered in favor of
the zombified manlet I mean I'm not gay
but would you rather make out with this
for this and one of the most talented
young actresses is squandered in a role
that has her put on a frumpy jumpsuit
and make two hours worth of cry face
don't worry cat it'll all be over soon
starring Peter pocket Team Jacob
50 shades of gray Elizabeth Banks on
this part to pay her mortgage woody
harrelson as himself Skrillex and none
of us have seen your boobs I mean
definitely not be a friend of mine sent
me a link but I said hey man that is not
okay
privacy is an important issue not
interested thank you very much because
that's not cool where's PETA part 1
women children ah no they didn't that
was you remember smooth move Hawkeye be
sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers I have been and always shall be
your friend the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few or the one
a solar eclipse the cosmic ballet goes
on of all the souls I've encountered in
my travels his was the most human live
long and prosper